okay so let's talk about the uh the this
is not happening you had this show on on
Comedy Central yeah well first I had
just we just did it live like the way
you did it right okay yeah and uh it
came out it was like a Big Show in
Comedy Central yeah it was the coolest
stand-up show they ever had for sure and
at one point like in between Seasons you
guys decided let's get like like as many
of the guys from jackasses we can to
come on stage and tell crazy stories and
just kind of feel it out and test it and
see if it would be a good episode yeah
so we do theme episodes and some of the
like travel stories some of the with
this whatever uh we were thinking of
having like a Tracy Morgan storytelling
show I'll probably do like just
everybody tells the difference there's
so many Tracy Morgan stories that I'm
like I could get four or five Comics
episode will be so easy for sure
is identical
yeah
you got like hundreds of people telling
precisely the same story Bad episode
Comedy Festival we'll get back to but
he's thrown out of a bar at like 2PM and
we're like any dick and he just throws
some he just takes some of those uh root
beer candies you know whatever
sounds off who the [ __ ] is this fairy
guy yeah yeah so um so themed episodes
and then it was gonna be uh yeah jackass
and we were like let's yeah I don't know
if we reached out to you first or
whatever but everybody was down it was
um everybody was down I think everybody
had a had a blast and that was the first
time for uh all the other guys to ever
get on the stage yeah oh yeah I remember
that because you were like people don't
realize they [ __ ] take some some work
to do stand up yeah and you had this
experience now so you were like hey guys
I actually like you can just tell like I
know what I'm doing with this microphone
right I mean distinctly the the trial
did not
um succeed because there was never a
jackass themed episode I think we I
think I lost the show pretty shortly
after that I can't I wonder when it was
that was 2015. it was 2015. yeah well it
wasn't that short after that
yeah that was still like a thing we
wanted to do I'm very interested in
hearing uh about the the losing of the
show what would like as I understood it
you recorded a special for Comedy
Central not just for myself for yourself
and then like it was going to be on
Comedy Central but you pulled it and
moved it somewhere else in that episode
yeah I'd upset well it's that's not it's
it's I got sick of taking notes from
people on my stand-up
um from like just some guy wearing a
suit like ah like I'll just do what I
want to do I'm sure you get it all the
time we're like maybe you shouldn't do
this you're like yeah I want to choose
my own show right like a live show like
I don't want you telling me what I
should do right thanks with the input
yeah maybe but you know I'll do what I
want right so at some point I was like
I'm just gonna make this myself and
figure it out
pay for it it was kind of one of the
early ones of doing that and then I made
it and then they made me an offer and I
was like
um I didn't take the offer right and
then I went to I just took off went to
Southeast Asia for a few months just for
fun you know I was like finished with
the season of the show yeah what do you
do for fun in Southeast Asia that sounds
so creepy
[ __ ] boys dude young boys where'd you go
I started at Myanmar just because like I
waited till like a day before and I was
like where's the weather the best and
there was like no rain in the Myanmar
forecast so I went there first
and then uh I called an Uber then I
threw my phone in the drawer and I just
[ __ ] went to the airport with no
phone I locked myself out of all my
accounts wow I like changed my passwords
like to just slamming on the keyboard
gave those to my friends and I'm like
don't don't give them to me so I
couldn't get on any like social media my
email I had no phone did you regret that
term no was it like a yeah nobody's
bothering me nobody no responsibility
right it was the greatest what what what
prompted this
I just wanted to travel yeah yeah and
Comedy Central was up my ass like no we
gotta do another show
come on we gotta do a season and I'm
like God I did it all right like you're
going right back in it's eight months of
editing to get everybody's story right
and then uh and then my buddy Duncan
Trussell he was just like well you want
to travel and see the world and they
want you to not travel to the world so
like what's the question even yeah right
and I'm like oh yeah you're right and so
I was like hey I'm out
um did you come back with any epiphanies
because I know like when I travel I'll
go for a month and then then you realize
what you really want yeah you start
seeing real clearly all the [ __ ]
chaff and your brain drops off and
you're just like what am I what do I
care about what do I like
um do you feel like you upped your game
when you came back on that trip what do
you mean about my game just kind of like
uh you realize what was important and
you just went [ __ ] straight for it
like did you get more successful after
that or were you've always been kind of
on us personally successful like not
you're there's like you're talking about
Creative Financial or like personal what
success is you know personal yeah for
sure like I went after what I wanted all
the time it was like this is all about
like what I'm trying to put out none of
this I'm already making money enough to
pay my rent yeah so like this is all
bonus people get lost in it for sure
people get lost trying to keep up with
their friends instead of like you're all
just we're all just writing dick jokes
and we're we're paying our rents
did you do any psychedelics in Southeast
Asia
found mushrooms one one time on lombok
in Indonesia that was pretty [ __ ]
chill because I feel like in Myanmar
don't they have those the the honey that
people go and try to get from the bees
that's psychedelic honey oh yeah I
didn't get any of that I just stayed in
hostels I was a nobody it was [ __ ] it
was it was bomb yeah it was just like
yeah nobody recognized nobody wanted
anything out of me it was just like such
Freedom like I think I'll go from this
city to this city and people like I
heard there's a [ __ ] Tomato Festival
over here like all right I'll change my
plan yeah and you just there was nowhere
to go
there was no you had to be it was great
the toilet took some getting used to
but like the the toads in the ground
yeah bum guns no no flushing or toilet
paper and what a great opportunity that
would be to promote Squatty Potty oh
absolutely
Stevo's butt wipes available right now
at stevo.com that's exactly where
they're available not only will they get
your butt squeaky clean but you're also
supporting one of the finest stuntman
and comedians in the country Stevo
that's for you
I dude don't make it look difficult
easy easy
they're butt wipes for your butthole
please
yeah let's see what we'll see what it
comes out as a little bit Brown nice
before that's uh especially after a
skank Fest weekend
[Laughter]
yeah dude
um oh anyway so I got back so I got back
and I was like let me so Netflix is only
doing celebrities at the time when I
when I was like first pitching my
special but then I'm like four or five
months passed and I'm like let me see
what they're up to I think they're
taking like regular people now
um they totally revamped and like I'm
Chappelle and only like you know 20
million dollar people and they'll be
like well we are actually like giving
seven seconds don't you have a deal with
Comedy Central I'm like no they have an
offer but no
and um nobody's watching comedy central
[ __ ] anymore it was like on its way way
down and then they were like all right
we'll give you an offer and then Comedy
Central was like
uh-uh right and they were like here's
the deal you got to do with us I'm like
no you guys don't have the reach plus it
was like a two-part special and they had
a platform to
to show two parts of anything right I
was like HBO wouldn't have the platform
either you just can't show it
and they said you have to and they said
if you don't they were like they're
contracted for 10 episodes but they were
gonna do 20 so I could get them all at
once if you don't we have to do 10 but
we're cutting you from 20 to 10 we're
going to fire all your employees who put
them out of work with a weak to spare
good luck paying their rent
um or you can walk away they appealed to
the compassion in you for others what a
bad mistake
I was like [ __ ] I was first of all well
played well played and then I was like
but I'm not gonna comply right so now
you were like yeah you you said good
luck to my employees and I'm with you
good luck to them yeah I'm going to
Netflix you're like I was gonna do that
anyway yeah so they found someone else
and kept the 20 episodes that was a
thing I should have been like I should
have played Hardball I should have been
like then do it then do it right all the
employees later were like what do you
mean that's part of it I'm like
[ __ ] what do you mean that shows
shows you know stop a week or two out
it's still a ten episodes it'll still be
a week of work right but they just kind
of blackmailed me it's called Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on Amazon and type in Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude